we will talk high heels and empathy in
Texas we'll also be talking about the
Nashville statement our Christians
really just sort of saying what they've
always believed Plus Nancy Pelosi does
something good i'll explain i'm ben
shapiro this is the ben shapiro so
yesterday president Trump travelled to
Texas with Melania and they landed in I
think it was Corpus Christi where they
met with the governor of Texas as well
Greg Abbott will talk about everything
that sprang there from and what the
media's narrative has been of course
it's been a garbage' narrative and we'll
talk about what that is but first I want
to say thank you to our sponsors over to
enzo Chino so you want to look good your
dude you want to look good and you don't
know the first thing about suits all you
do is you go to your local department
store and you pick something off the
rack and you think oh this is probably
fine no it looks like you're running
drapes that's why you need to go over to
my friends at Enzo Chino okay they give
you customized suits they get you
customized suits that are tailor-made
for you and they are making it very very
easy you choose from hundreds of top
quality fabrics you personalize your
suit just the way you want it whether
for work a wedding or another special
occasion they've suited up hundreds of
thousands of men my favorite suit is an
Enzo chinos it's actually a three-piece
er I don't wear it that often because
you know vests but it's pretty cool and
it fits perfectly because that's what
Enzo chinos in the business of doing you
can either go over to one of their
showrooms in some major cities or you go
over to Enzo Chino dot-com and shop
online you pick your fabric you choose
your customizations from appelles to
pleats to jacket linings you submit your
measurements online then you place your
order and you wait for it to arrive in
just a few weeks this week my listeners
get any premium Indo Chino suit for just
three hundred seventy nine dollars at
Enzo Chino calm when you enter Schapiro
at checkout that's Indo Chino commenter
Shapiro I check out and you get any
premium Enzo Chino suit for just three
hundred seventy nine bucks less than you
would pay for an off-the-rack suit at
one of those expensive department stores
that's 50% off the regular price from
made-to-measure premium suit plus the
shipping is free again it's the suit
that will fit you best and it's the suit
that will look the best you can select
the material you can make all the
customizations you want super cool you
sort of feel like James Bond that you
get these custom-made suits Indo Chino
kaam promo code Shapiro for any premium
suit for under three hundred and seventy
nine dollars and free shipping so go
check it out right now ENSO chinos calm
preman use that promo code Shapiro so
that they know that we sent you as well
okay so yesterday President Trump goes
to Texas and the reason that we have
politicians go to these places is
because if we don't then the media
suggests that they're bad people
that's how this game works when george w
bush did a flyover of hurricane katrina
back in 2006-2007 then the media went
nuts how dare george w bush do such a
thing
how could George W Bush not actually
land in New Orleans and and take care of
business on the ground like I always
thought this was stupid because I'm not
sure exactly why it is it certainly 2005
I'm not sure why it is that the George W
Bush what was he gonna do on the ground
was he gonna like get out and start
bailing I was he gonna go to a homeless
shelter and start handing out food in a
way that no other two human hands on the
planet could do it seems like a massive
distraction to me whenever a president
does this it seemed like a distraction
when Obama wanted to do this during
Hurricane sandy and then Chris Christie
hosted him in New Jersey I'm not a big
fan of this whole the president has to
go there like he's the king like he's
the Emperor and he must land and now he
will bring order to a chaotic situation
like did anyone feel more secure the
Trump went that's not a rip on Trump
that's a rip on the system Trump did
what he had to do he went there because
if he hadn't then the media would have
ripped him up and down so naturally the
media focused on a couple of aspects of
this that are completely irrelevant the
federal response to hurricane Harvey has
been quite good so far there's been no
evidence that the feds have been asleep
on the job not sleep at the switch the
state response has been quite good the
city response the local response has
been quickly everybody did what they've
been doing which is why you have this
historic flooding in Houston and I
believe we're still in single digits as
far as the number of people who are dead
which every one of those a tragedy but
let's be real if this flood happened in
a third-world country to be talked about
tens of thousands of people dead not I
think it's now six individuals dead in
this in this lighting seven individuals
dead by the time it's over I'm sure
there'll be a couple of dozen people who
died but that is a testament to the
emergency services and the capacity of
the government to to help out in
situations like this but is that what
the media are focused on no they're
focused on all the optics because
whenever
Trump is attending place it's all about
the optics Oh Trump arrives and he's
wearing his USA hat because that's what
he does and Melania all of the focuses
are Melania in terms of a lot of the
optics so the first focus was on the
fact that when she was lead
the white house she was wearing heels
okay so she then changed on the plane
and she was wearing sneakers when she
got there which makes him sense but why
do we care about her shoes again just
confused as to that who knows she was
wearing heels zach braff of scrubs fame
said that he wanted to dress in
milania's heels for halloween you undo
Milania going to a disaster zone for
Halloween and then Milania shows up and
she looked beautiful because she's a
beautiful woman and she's wearing a hat
that says on it FLOTUS as his First Lady
of the United States so you've got Trump
wearing his us a hat and she's wearing a
hat that says who she is
which I got to admit I'm never a huge
fan of this particular look when when it
would like it would be the equivalent of
me wearing a ben shapiro thug-life hat
around like he's just like if you don't
know who Milania is she's the wife of
the president like did you pick up on
that so not my favorite thing but is it
a big deal of course it's not a big deal
like seriously that's the big deal so
Trump arrives and Trump talks about the
cleanup in Texas okay so there's nothing
wrong with that people were saying this
is all self aggrandizing okay have you
never met Trump have you never seen the
guy like so the hell what is the job
getting governor's the job not getting
done and then what they really jumped on
is he shows up at basically it looks
like a truck yard in in Corpus Christi
and he explained and he starts sort of
pitching himself as as a public figure
he talked about the crowd right he talks
about crowd size this is Trump's schtick
okay if you don't get it by now then
you're never gonna get it this is what
Trump does
[Music]
thank you everybody what a crowd what a
turnout I want to thank our governor has
done who's right here somebody's right
here so we just want to thank your
governor senator Cruz to the cordon okay
so everybody in media goes nuts over
this how could he say what a crowd how
could he say what a turnout why is his
focus on the crowd in the turnout okay I
admit it's uncouth does anyone really
care is this the biggest deal
oh what a crowd like that's what we're
gonna that's what I'm gonna nitpick over
now he's doing a good job with the
response but that's what we're gonna
nitpick over and then they double down
because Trump also said that this is all
about you know how it's gonna be that he
wants people to be able to congratulate
each other when this is over on their
response again is this a big deal we
won't say congratulations we don't want
to do that
[Applause]
yeah Greg Abbott looking real awkward
there and so the media of course decide
that this is just insane because really
the story here is not Trump's capacity
and his administration's capacity to
handle a disaster hey let's be real
about this for one second okay a month
ago if you would have said there's a
major disaster on American soil do you
think the Trump administration can
handle it
the media would universally have said no
not've said he's understaffed he doesn't
know it he's doing he's a buffoon and
the handling of this has been pretty
good and a handling this has been pretty
smooth so instead what the media choose
to focus on is empathy they choose to
focus on feelings Trump you see wasn't
empathetic enough here's a little
montage cut by our own Robert Cray check
over at daily wire of all the members of
the media focusing in on just the
horrific nature of Trump's statements
how could he not be more empathetic
where is the man's empathy where are his
feelings where is his heart and briefly
to Donald Trump have his empathy moment
today he didn't have the empathy moment
yet but he's done a very good job except
for asking or complimenting the crowd
sighs that came out to greet him
anything up if he's never been his
strong suit
hug a mom or hold a baby or shake
someone's hand or ask a senior how they
were doing it was really remarkable he
acted like this was a big field trip and
it was the biggest and the best response
and we're gonna congratulate each other
later it was typical Donald Trump was
that without an ounce of them but is he
ever been exposed to a situation and Jim
those words there show that the
president is still very much learning on
the job in terms of empathy learning on
jobs on the job in terms of how to react
and relate to the individuals here who
are the human element seem to be absent
outside of the self congratulatory
gestures of the press conference it
seems to me it's just concerned about
optics just concerned about optics and I
want to be concerned well wish they
would be concerned about people they
were saying that it's going to be key to
see the way he has real feelings and
real empathy how does he respond in this
first big situation like this what will
you be looking for the empathy factor
there's the response there as making
people feel like he's engaged and he's
going to be Alicia's
what present property is trying to
convey today in his visit and
appropriately so he is going to have to
show some real feeling some real empathy
to the people in Texas that have been
hit in this devastating manner in that
way it remains to be seen what the
empathy factor is going to be on message
yeah I think he understands things
around message can we stop it there
because he just goes on and on you think
they're on message about the empathy
thing okay so a couple of things are
worth noting here one President Trump
does not have to be an actor okay we're
not sitting here evaluating whether he
should be cast in the role of Iago or
whether he should be cast as Desdemona
okay with it's not important the this
whole presidents have to show empathy
routine I'm a big fan of Calvin Coolidge
because Calvin Coolidge didn't truck
with this BS Calvin Coolidge was
basically look here's my job I'm gonna
do my job and then I'm gonna go play
golf like this isn't his woman to do I'm
gonna do it I'm gonna go back in my room
I'm not gonna bother you it's not
important for me to get on the radio
it's not important for me to be a public
figure but now we have to do this whole
well he didn't shed a tear I remember
during the Obama administration after
there was some there was an actor
there's some gun violence Massacre there
was a massacre using a gun and Obama
went out and did a press conference and
he said it's here with me oh my god look
at the feelings of him look how much he
feels he feels for you he feels for me
he's just Jesus like in his feeling for
everyone this routine where if Trump
would just show a little more empathy
the media would be on his side are you
kidding they'd find something else to
nitpick
I mean Melania released a statement
yesterday and here's what it said it
said the effects of Hurricane Harvey
will be felt in Texas Louisiana and
other parts of the country for many
months and years to come so far 1.7
million people are under orders to
evacuate their homes and as the flood
water in Houston Rises sadly so will the
number of evacuees I want to be able to
offer my help and support in the most
productive way possible not through just
words but also action what I found
through the most profound during the
visit was not only the strength and
resilience of the people of Texas but
the compassion and sense of community
that has taken over the state my
thoughts and prayers continue to be with
the people of the Texas in Louisiana it
seems rather empathetic to me but the
overall drive for empathy I think is
actually a serious political problem for
a couple of reasons and I'll explain
those in just one second but first I
want to say thank you to our sponsors
over at stamps.com
so are you tired of waiting in line at
the post office you don't have time to
run over to the grocery store and get
the stamps
don't know how to weigh your postage
stamps calm takes care of all of it they
bring all the services of the US Postal
Service right to your fingertips you can
buy in prints official US postage for
any letter any package any class of mail
using your own computer and printer and
stamps comm makes it easy they'll send
you a digital scale it automatically
calculates exact postage and then you
can print out the postage directly onto
the envelope you can print it onto a
sticker you can print it onto a piece of
paper and tape it onto the envelope
there's no need to lease an expensive
postage meter I use stamps calm because
we heard the office mail things all the
time and there's no reason for us to
constantly be running over to a mail
shop go to stamps calm click on the
microphone at the top of the home page
type in promo code Shapiro that stamps
calm type click on the microphone and
then hit Shapiro and you get a four week
trial plus postage and the digital scale
without any long-term commitment so
that's pretty amazing go over to stamps
calm in that four-week trial plus
postage and digital scale stamps
comments our promo code Shapiro never go
to the post office again again use that
promo code Shapiro also that they know
that we sent you okay so here is I have
two specific problems with this whole
empathy routine from the media number
three one is that it's obviously
hypocritical the media doesn't care
about Trump's level of empathy they have
a goal which is to paint him as uncaring
and mean right the Democrats constantly
Democrats in the media they have a three
pronged attack on people in in
Republican halls of power they are
stupid they are corrupt or they are evil
so they've already tried stupid with
Trump and it's only gotten them so far
corrupt they're they're still trying and
it's only gotten them so far so now in
this situation where he's demonstrated
in either stupidity nor corruption they
have to go to their third prong which is
he's evil he actually doesn't empathize
with the people who are in harm's way
like really do you really think that
Trump at night he's just gonna screw
those people in Texas screw them I'm so
glad there's a flood do you really think
that's who Trump is because that would
really be evil I don't think that's who
Trump is you may be oblivious he may be
a buffoon sometimes but is that what
you're seeing here because that's not
what I'm seeing here and the media are
obviously
attempting to exaggerate the case and
make a case that he's a meaning a big
meanie
even though he's doing the job and
specifically because he's doing the job
okay second point here and but the in
politics actually makes for bad policy
it makes for bad policy as I've
referenced before empathy in politics
leads you to have empathy for the person
who's directly in
front of you without looking at the
broader cost so empathy leads you to a
situation like hurricane sandy where
after Hurricane sandy Democrats in
Congress decided they wanted to load up
the hurricane sandy funding with a bunch
of pork I loaded up a pork I was there I
remember okay we all remember this chris
Christie is now denying this that's
because chris Christie is totally full
of it the fact is they did load up the
hurricane sandy bill of pork why because
they were using empathy as an excuse to
be corrupt
so we empathize with the people who are
harmed by Hurricane sandy and therefore
it is very very important that we load
up as much pork into this bill as
possible and pass something and if you
don't do it then you lack empathy then
you are a bad person
empathy leads you to focus on the
specific beneficiary of a policy as
opposed to the disparate and diffuse
group of individuals who are hurt by a
given policy so in this particular case
listen we have FEMA we have a state
government we have local governments and
they're all doing their job but the idea
here from the Democrats is that empathy
really has to come down to how much
money is Trump going to spend not does
the job get done but we can measure
empathy in dollars we can measure
empathy in dollars which is sort of an
amazing thing for Democrats to say
considering that people who give charity
in this country happen to be mostly
Republican the average amount of charity
coming out of Republican households is
much higher than it is coming out of
Democratic households but then we're
called selfish okay if you're gonna
measure empathy and money I would
suggest you start with charity but for
Democrats what they really mean is that
if you're truly empathetic you're ready
to sign a check to the government
because the government can cure all your
problems if you just give your cash to
the government so for instance I saw a
headline today that was talking about
school lunches in Houston apparently the
local government is now saying that they
want to provide free school lunches to
all the kids in Houston for 2017-2018
ok that's their prerogative but then I
saw a tweet from a Democrat saying this
is what Republicans have been fighting
against all over the country number one
the entire country was not just hit by
51 inches of rain and people didn't lose
you know millions of homes presumably
number two you know the school lunches
let's I want to be clear about something
private charity fills a lot of the gap
for this sort of stuff you know much
money the Red Cross is taken in since
the beginning of this hurricane I mean
it's an enormous sum of money it's it
truly is you can tell where that where a
lot of the left's sort of priorities lie
Linda Sarsour has now put out a tweet
calling for people
to donate to what she's calling the
hurricane Harvey Relief Fund the
hurricane Harvey Relief Fund is
apparently and reportedly a political
organizing committee that is designed
toward lobbying the government it's not
actually charity that goes directly to
victims it is instead of social
organizing force to get people to lobby
the government to give more money to the
victims of Hurricane Harvey and to in
particular minority groups who are
harmed by hurricane Harvey it just
demonstrates where the left head is at
in all of this so second reason why I
don't like the empathy argument is that
the empathy argument suggests that you
are somehow a better person if you spend
more money empathy is really a stand-in
for cash empathy is just a politically
savvy maneuver by Democrats in order for
them to claim that you're not empathetic
enough if you don't want to give them
what they want they're like this all the
time right this is what I said to Piers
Morgan about gun control his implication
was if I didn't want gun control it's
because I wasn't empathetic enough for
Democrats you can measure the level of
your effectiveness by the level of your
empathy
I don't measure effectiveness by empathy
I'm as your effectiveness by
effectiveness I measure empathy by
empathy and I honestly don't care that
much what's in your heart
I can much more about what you do so
those are the first two reasons why this
empathy schpeel is wrong one is the
democrats in the media are being
hypocritical about it this is all ruse
second when they say empathy what they
really mean is spending lots and lots of
government money that's the second
reason that this empathy nonsense is is
wrong and the third reason is because
obviously - misdirection away from from
what's going on with Trump they won't
give Trump credit and so instead they
decide to focus on the empathy question
oh if only he'd shown his heart oh if
only he had gone and he'd wept oh if
only he'd there is something to the idea
that if you go into a chaotic situation
and rather than demonstrating that you
care you demonstrate that you're in
control that's actually more useful if I
were a victim of some sort of natural
disaster what I wouldn't care very much
about is a politician coming in and
giving me a hug or my wife a hug I don't
need a hug I have a wife for that and
what I would care about is the
politician coming in and saying here's
what I'm going to do to take care of
this right if I were a victim on the
ground what I'd want from Greg Abbott
and Donald Trump is not oh I care so
much about you
oh I care so much what I'd want is
action that was effective and that's
actually what we're seeing in this
circumstance so again the empathy thing
is a ruse it's used by the media in
order to promote a particular policy
agenda don't buy into it
don't buy into what the left is doing
here because the fact is Trump is doing
a good job here and I haven't seen any
evidence to the contrary and Trump is
always gonna be Trump he's never gonna
say the thing you want him to say but is
that a huge deal ask the people of Texas
the ones who are actually being harmed
did they look up in arms and one of my
favorite things about that clip of the
people shouting back from about the Jeff
Zeleny at CNN talking about Trump being
non empathetic one of my favorite things
the guy in the background shouting CNN
fake news as this happens pretty amazing
but I think indicative of the difference
between the political viewpoints okay so
I also want to talk about what disaster
shows us about the roles of different
kinds of human beings I want to talk
about Nancy Pelosi making a statement
that actually was really necessary oh
and give you an update on Berkeley the
Berkeley administration still throwing
up roadblocks to this event it's amazing
we'll talk about that and what they can
do to facilitate and also I want to talk
about this Nashville statement that the
media are going nuts over so a lot to
get to but for that you're gonna have to
go over and subscribe nine nine nine a
month gets you a subscription to The
Daily wire you get the rest of this show
it's a video show not just an audio show
so if you listen and you want to watch
you can go over to Daley wire comm for
$9.99 a month you can watch this show
live you can watch Michael Moses show
live you can watch Andrew Clemens show
live you watch the entirety of them and
then when we post them later we cut out
the ad so you can watch them ad freeze
that's pretty cool you also if you get
the annual subscription you get this the
very greatest you know all beverage
vessels leftist here's hot or cold daily
wire tumbler you will enjoy it it is
glorious is having even steven crowder
who tried to destroy it said that it
really took a fair bit of doing to
destroy this mug as opposed to his
mother I mean I just blew on his mug and
it fell apart let's be yeah we have to
be honest here no no false advertising
in any case you can get that with a $99
a year subscription plus if you just
want to listen over to iTunes or
SoundCloud later please subscribe leave
leave leave the please leave us a review
we always appreciate it we are the
largest and fastest-growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
all righty so let's talk a little bit
about what Hurricane Katrina does in
terms of reinforcing reality one of the
reasons I think people like disaster
fiction one of the reasons I think
people like to watch movies like The
Hunger Games is because we have an
innate sense than when we are in crisis
our true identity shines forth then when
crisis strikes people go back to the
basics and that's what you're seeing in
Hurricane Katrina I talked about the in
hurricane Harvey well as I talked about
a couple of days ago I think that what
you're seeing in terms of people helping
each other out that is the innate sense
of Americans I think that people all
over the world want to help each other
out in times of disaster but there is
something else that I think is worth
noting and that is there been a couple
of pictures that I think people find
really moving and
to moving for a reason there's one
picture in particular that I thought was
very moving his picture of a man holding
a woman holding a child he's trying to
bring her out of the flood and he's
holding the woman and she's holding the
child the fact is the gender roles are
relatively well defined in biology and
the reason for that is because the
diversity of the gender role is a great
thing it's so funny the left is very
into diversity except when it comes to
actual gender roles then all of a sudden
they suggest that these are all
arbitrary and meaningless but the fact
is that when disaster strikes it is
largely men who are charging into
situations to try and save women and
children and other people okay a society
that is not built on men trying to help
each other will be built on men trying
to destroy each other male gender roles
that are all about men protecting yeah
that's a good thing that's something we
ought to be cheering and you see some
people who are very upset when you say
this oh how dare you there are women out
there too hot that's true
there are women who are out there
helping for sure and no one's denying
that and no one is deriding them helping
but if a man is not protective if we
have a society of men who are not
protective they will instead be
destructive this is just how we from the
time boys are little boys they're either
building with blocks or they are
destroying the blocks that they just
built these are the two things that they
do men are built for protection or they
are built for destruction and when you
see disaster strike what you see is a
lot of heroic men charging into the line
of fire and that's a good thing and what
you see is a lot of heroic women
protecting their children he said a lot
of heroic women whose first priority is
to protect their kids and you see that
kids are treated as kids innocents to be
protected not children to be manipulated
for political purposes not children free
and capable of making their own
decisions about life but small human
beings who must be protected because
they're innocent and aren't capable of
taking care of themselves that is a good
thing these are all good things the male
role as protector is a good thing and
something worth celebrating the female
role the female role as guardian of the
family as guardian of the children that
is a good thing it's not a bad thing and
I don't know why women would want to
give that up honest to god I don't and
this is not coming from someone who says
that all women have to stay in the home
lately I've been spending more time at
home that my wife hasn't mean she's
she's a medical resident but when when
push comes to shove my job is to protect
my wife and my wife's job is to protect
my children and she knows that and I
know that and a society that's not built
on this innate biological Drive is death
to fail the left strive to destroy all
three parts of that it's really
horrifying to say that men they're not
really protectors they're just they're
they're dispensable men are dispensable
and women suggesting well you know it's
not really our job to take care of
children children can take care of
themselves star job to work and left is
suggesting the children are capable of
making their own decisions about sexual
orientation and gender identity you know
all of this is a is an overriding of the
of the innate biological good diversity
between men women and children that
truly does exist okay speaking of all of
that I want to talk a little bit about
the National statement so for people who
don't know what the National statement
is the evangelical community has brought
out something called the Nashville
statement okay on Friday August 25th the
council on Biblical manhood and
womanhood in the ethics and religious
liberty commission jointly hosted a
gathering of Christian leaders in
Nashville they wanted to finalize and
approve the National statement in the
hope of providing a biblically faithful
standard is according to desire in god
org and the nashville statement has made
a lot of fuss there are a lot of people
on the Left who are very deeply upset
with the National statement because the
national statement does something
terrible it reinforces all of biblical
Christianity's views about sexuality oh
it's always really weird and curious to
me that so many folks on the Left are
confused whenever Christians believe in
the gospel
whenever Jews believe in the Bible like
that's the definition guys
Lauren Zuka who's just adult
oh she writes for Teen Vogue which means
that she is one of our nation's
preeminent public intellectuals she
tweeted out that if Jesus were alive
today he'd be turning water into wine
and gay weddings no he most assuredly
would not no he most assuredly would not
read a book a book not like many books
like Reed Grover goes to school and
you'll be more informed about the Bible
than you currently are clearly because
this is insanity okay so here's what the
National statement says this is not to
suggest that public policy has to
reflect the National statement but
public policy does have to reflect
protection for people who are religious
and believe in the National statement
that is something public policy does
have to do you don't have to agree with
the National statement but for you to
try and hijack somebody else's religion
is ridiculous it's like every time the
Pope comes down says
portions bad and left goes oh darn it we
thought this time he was really gonna
come around on this or when the Pope
says same-sex marriage is not something
that hath like church believes in and
left goes we were this close
no you weren't that close again it's
been Catholic doctrine since the very
beginning so the National statement
affirms that God has designed marriage
to be covenant --all sexual procreative
lifelong union of one man and one woman
as husband and wife if this comes as a
shock to you it's because you're stupid
and they deny that God has designed
marriage to be a homosexual polygamists
or polyamorous and they deny marriage is
a mere human contract rather than
Covenant made with God I agree with all
of this by the way on a personal level
again this doesn't reflect public policy
I think the government should get
completely out of the business of
marriage I agree it is a covenant made
before God I don't know what government
has to do with a covenant made before
God article two says we affirm that
God's revealed will for all people is
chastity outside of marriage and
fidelity within marriage okay again
agreed I was a virgin until marriage so
is my wife
they say we deny that any affections
desires or commitments ever justify
sexual intercourse before or outside
marriage nor do they justify any form of
sexual immorality okay again this is a
basic Christian worldview a basic
judeo-christian worldview actually the
idea that just because you want to do
something doesn't mean you get to do
something or that it's justified they
say we affirm that God created Adam and
Eve the first human beings in his own
image
equal before God as persons and distinct
is male and female and deny that the
divinely ordained differences between
male and female render them unequal in
dignity or worth again this is all just
rote stuff this is thought there's no
big deal here they say we affirm the
differences between male and female
reproductive structures are integral to
God's design for self conception as male
or female so in other words gender is
not independent of sex again this is
right they say we affirm that those born
with a physical disorder of sex
development are created in the image of
God and have dignity and worth equal to
all other image bearers we have firm
that self conception as male or female
should be defined by God's holy purposes
in creation and redemption as revealed
in Scripture and they say they deny that
adopting a homosexual or transgender
self conception is consistent with God's
holy purposes in creation and redemption
okay again this is traditional Christian
worldview this is not suggesting that
you're here here's where I still have a
slight difference you know if you
conceive of yourself as homosexual or
transgender in my view that's your
or orientations your business your
action is God's business and and the
religious communities business how you
orient is up to you because desires are
desires this is I think a significant
difference actually between Christian
thought and Jewish thought Jewish
thought is very little about what you
think and very much about what you do
and Christian thought is very much about
what you feel as well as what you do so
this is difference but to suggest that
this isn't in line with Christian
thinking for the last couple thousand
years is just asinine you know this is
everything they say here in other words
is is totally within the bounds of
Christianity and yet the left is
Superman because the left is Superman
that there are people who disagree with
them tolerance and diversity for the
left end at my religious my religious
observance
that's when tolerance and diversity and
which is why government has a job
protecting religious diversity it's why
government has a job saying you don't
get to encroach on me and I don't get to
encroach on you but this idea that you
get to encroach on me because you don't
like what I'm doing okay it's fascism
and the left left hatred for the
National statement demonstrates like I
don't understand why they even care as I
said I've said this a thousand times
whether I consider your behavior sinful
or not it's completely irrelevant to you
why do you care what I think it's a free
country
feel free not to care but the left does
care because deep down what the left
wants when it comes to social issues is
legitimacy moral legitimacy for their
viewpoints they can't get it from the
church they look to government to quash
the church and then look to government
as the sort of absolve err of all of
their sexual feelings okay so in other
news I want to talk a little bit about
the latest on the antifa
Berkeley situation because it continues
to unfold so the so Nancy Pelosi did
something I thought was actually quite
good shockingly she has now released a
statement it says our democracy has no
room for inciting violence or
endangering the public no matter the
ideology of those who commit such acts
the violent actions of people calling
themselves an Tifa in berkeley this
weekend deserve unequivocal condemnation
and the perpetrator should be arrested
and prosecutors prosecuted in california
as across all of our great nation we
have deep reverence for the
constitutional right to peaceful dissent
and free speech non-violence is
fundamental to that right let us use the
sad event to reaffirm that we must never
fight hate with hate and to remember the
values of peace openness and justice
that represent the best of America Wow
Nancy Pelosi
the Botox receded long enough for her to
issue that statement that's a very good
statement by Nancy Pelosi good for you
representative Pelosi really that is
that is good stuff I hope that this is
the beginning of the Democratic
establishment beginning to disassociate
from antiva because what we're seeing
instead in Berkeley is some politicians
who are willing to make way for an anti
feh there they're throwing another
roadblock up believe it or not with
regards to my event September 14th in
Berkeley I want to make a quick
distinction between my events and the
free speech week that comes I believe a
week and a half later in Berkeley
that's one featuring and closer and
maybe Steve Benin and maybe Milo I
believe Milo is definitely gonna speak
there he's one of the organizers that's
happening after my event my event is
September 14th both of them have been
approved by Berkley but just the news
coverage have been conflating the two
they're not the same events and not all
the people hold the same views obviously
but regardless everybody there has the
rights of free speech just as I have a
right to free speech so what is Berkley
doing now so Berkeley still has not
released tickets okay it is now August
30th the event is on September 14th and
about you but virtually all concerts
release tickets months in advance okay
the idea that you're going to release
tickets I guess maybe two weeks in it
they're now talking about next week
releasing tickets giving people like a
week and a half to sign up we already
have nearly 2,000 people who have signed
up through yeah org for the event itself
and we're going to try and translate
those over to tickets at Berkeley what
is Berkeley doing apparently they're now
trying to require that the F and the
College Republicans tell everybody that
if you want to pick up your ticket you
have to come the day before before or
5:00 p.m. to pick it up if they won't
mail them out that they won't print them
out then instead you have to physically
come there the day before before 5:00
p.m.
does that sound like they're trying to
throw up a roadblock to filling out the
the auditorium it certainly does to me
I've never heard of a public event where
we have to arrive the day before in
person to pick up your tickets have you
ever heard of something like this
Malthus I've never heard of something
like this I mean if every ticketing
system in America and around the world
allows you to print out your ticket at
home allows you to pick up your ticket
at the box office the day of yeah this
is total madness and it's obvious that
they're trying to throw up obstacles at
this point please if you have a chance
go over to youch org and register for
the event and they have the information
for Berkeley's administration they
should be letting know by you that this
is unacceptable okay all we want to do
go and have an event talking about free
speech and aunt Eva and the alt-right
and black lives matter and social
justice warriors and hit on all these
hot-button issues in a in a in a I think
well-thought-out way that's all we want
to do and exercising those free speech
rights is made difficult even by the
people who pledge to uphold them over at
Berkeley which is really quite
astounding so I would hope that Berkeley
does its job and releases the tickets
ASAP and forthwith because I know that
there are literally thousands of people
who want to show up okay time for things
I like and then we'll do some things I
hate and then we'll do a little bit of
Bible talk so things I like we've been
doing a little bit of philosophy this
week another book on philosophy that was
held near and zere by a lot of the early
a lot of the early conservatives in the
country was Edmund Burke's reflections
on the revolution in France one of the
great differences between some of the
founders was how they felt about the
French Revolution some people like John
Adams saw the French Revolution as
dangerous which it was some people like
Thomas Jefferson initially loved the
French Revolution and thought that this
was the overthrow of the old order and
something new would be built in its
place Burke's reflections on the
revolution in France Brooke was a
supporter of the American Revolution and
and Burke was a believer in
representative democracy not to wreck
democracy his book reflections on the
revolution of France basically predicts
what is going to happen in the
Revolution and why it's going to fall
apart right he was because it did fall
apart it turns out when the community
overthrows the individual that
revolutions fall apart the difference
between the American Revolution and the
French Revolution is that the American
Revolution was based on the idea that
human beings are endowed by their
creator
creators with certain inalienable rights
and that government is enshrined in
order and empowered in order to protect
those individual rights the French
Revolution was based on the idea that
all rights spring from governments and
the community and therefore the
community has the ability to overrule
individual rights in any situation where
it sees fit to do so pretty different
revolution Brooke points that out and he
points out the value of respecting
tradition particularly if you don't know
what it is there's a I think it's Robert
Frost who says this but I but I'm not
sure who says that the noce I'm sorry
it's Chesterton who makes the argument
out of offenses he says that you know
the difference seen a conservative and a
leftist is that a conservative sees
offense in the middle of a field and
says to himself
don't know why that fence is there maybe
I should find out why that fence is
there before removing it I left this
seize a fence in the middle of the field
and says there's no reason for this
fence to be here I'm removing it I think
that's a pretty good summation of the
the main thrust of Edmund Burke's
reflections on the revolution in France
okay other things that I like so there's
been a lot of talk about Colin
Kaepernick a crappy quarterback for the
49ers kneeling for the national anthem
and now they're a bunch of people on the
horrifyingly Bad Cleveland Browns who
kneel for the national anthem good for a
Cowboys QB dak Prescott who is asked
specifically about kneeling for the
national anthem here's what he had to
say as the thought crossed your mind
about participating do you feel they
need to do so no not at all well why not
why do you feel the need to not
participate in that I mean it's it's
bigger than then I think some of us
think I mean it's just important for me
to go out there and over my heart
represent our country I just be thankful
and not take anything I've been given
and and then there's my freedom offer
granite
good for him good for him I don't
understand why this is so tough for
people to say if you have problems with
the system fight the system but if you
are going to you know if you're going to
fight the national anthem all the
unifying features of the country
themselves then you're undermining those
unifying feature is good for dak
Prescott I'm now rooting for dak
Prescott seems like a good guy this does
the stuff does make difference folks if
that seems shallow that I don't root for
Colin Kaepernick because I think that
his views on America are negative and
destructive but I do root for dak
Prescott because I think that his views
on politics are good maybe your solution
ought to be removing politics from
sports altogether maybe that ought to be
your solution but as so long as politics
is gonna be infused into sports then I'm
gonna root for guys like dak Prescott
who seems like a much better human being
than Colin Kaepernick at least so far as
his views on the country are concerned
okay time for some things that I hate
so Kathy Griffin has been out of the
news for a few months ever since she did
a photo shoot at which he held up the
mock mock-up of a bloody head bloody
decapitated head of President Trump she
hasn't been in the news so she's decided
it's time to get back in the news this
time by reneging on her apology which
just demonstrates why fake apologies are
stupid in the first place
here she is are you no longer sorry for
it correct I'm no longer sorry
the whole outrage was BS the whole thing
got so blown out of proportion and I
lost everybody like I had Chelsea
Clinton tweeting against me I had
friends Debra Messing from willing Grace
tweeting against me I mean I lost
everybody and so I have been through the
mill and I also you know I didn't just
lose like one night on CNN my entire
tour was canceled within 24 hours
because every single theater got all
these death threats I mean these Trump
fans they're hardcore they have like
robo calls and they're a minority but we
know how to act like they're a majority
Debra Messing and Chelsea Clinton on
Trump fans like if even Democrats said
it was out of line I get that comedy is
about pushing the boundaries and being
politically incorrect and that's fine
but do you not agree that that picture
holding up a severed head I know it's a
mask covered in tomato sauce but did you
not accept that was a little bit over
the line no you're full of crap stop
this you know this stop acting like my
little picture is more important than
talking about the actual atrocities that
the president of the United States is
committing okay what atrocities involve
the President of the United States
holding up the bloodied severed head of
his political enemies I'm missing that
part it is amazing look she just wants
attention
she wasn't able to get it with her
original shtick in a way that she liked
so now she's walking it back and she's
she's will it here's the thing she knows
that a lot of the people on the Left are
gonna quietly accept her back that if
she does this she feels stronger right
that it makes her stronger than all
these people are going to now walk back
from their original anger at Kathy
Griffin they're gonna say well she was
misguided she apologized in the first
place and people weren't willing to
accept for apology so screw it
she's on our side you know that's the
the direction in which they're going to
move
quickly here that's the part that I hate
Kathy Griffin I think is completely
irrelevant but it does demonstrate that
when people on the left to decide that
it is imperative to to make headlines by
ripping Trump and then apologize for it
later the apology is completely false
Don Lemon on CNN whose show I enjoy
doing but Don Lemon did did a segment
last night another thing I hate in which
he suggested that President Trump
doesn't like his black critics
particularly there's a racism in the way
that Trump treats his critics there are
lots of people on this network and
others who don't look like me who are
harder on this president and who say
disparaging things about this president
but he doesn't get as upset with them as
he does with me why is that okay it's a
ridiculous question the idea that Trump
is only upside down lemon because Don
Lemon is black is just ridiculous Trump
is one of most petty human beings on the
planet okay the idea that he's not upset
with white people who are mad at him or
women who are mad at him I mean Don
Lemon hasn't gotten half of what megyn
kelly got just during the election cycle
and if you're gonna talk about people
who have been targeted because they
didn't like Trump okay there are a
number of people who have been very
critical of Trump I mean he's going
after sitting senators in his own party
he's going after Jeff Flake who's a
senator of his own party the hell is Don
Lemon talking about but again everything
for the left has to be infused with this
extra degree of voracious nastiness and
when you do that all you're doing is
playing right into Trump hands beat
Trump's hands because everybody can see
that this is nonsense okay final thing
that I hate a lot of people are all over
the cni I just said something about a
CNN host that was negative now I'm gonna
say something about a CNN reporter that
is actually not so a lot of people are
all over the CNN reporter she's on the
ground during hurricane Harvey and she's
being asked about and she asks a
hurricane victim about the situation on
the ground and the hurricane victim
really goes after her on camera a lot of
the right was was overjoyed with this
let me introduce you to Danielle here
Daniel you just arrived share with us
how you were rescued some guys they
caught our phone and asked us where we
work we was waiting for the police for
like
thirty-six hours and they never came and
we was waiting at the home we did the
white flags and everything and nobody
came but then somebody had called the
phone after we decided to leave the
house we had walked it against they
with the kids and then they had called
it came he picked us up but we had been
there like five days with no food no
lights and nobody came like nobody came
now you're with your children we've
heard of stories of mothers trying to
save their children from the rushing
waters can you tell us how that was four
feet of water to go get them food on the
first day yeah that's a lot of fish I'll
sit here y'all trying to interview
people during their worst times like
that not the smartest thing to do like
people are really breaking down and
y'all sitting here with cameras and
microphones don't ask cuz what them is
wrong with it you really trying to
understand with the microphone still in
my face when me shivering cold with my
kids wet are you still putting a
microphone in my face everybody's all
over the reporter oh look at this woman
this woman's really speaking truth to
power okay I have a couple problems with
this one
the woman clearly agreed to be on camera
before this happened and the reporters
don't just run up to people and thrust a
microphone in their face they asked them
for their permission before they
interview them okay I've done it myself
his notion that that the reporter did
something wrong here is absurd I
understand why this woman would be
emotional and upset I understand even
why she'd be upset with the media who
may feel like they're Hawks here but
let's be real about one thing the fact
is that if the media were not covering
hurricane Harvey the amount of charity
flowing into funds to help people with
hurricane Harvey would be much lower
it is media coverage that drives
people's empathy okay you want to talk
about empathy as cash this is what it is
can people empathize with that mother
because they saw her on TV and then they
want to send cash and that's good in the
realm of private charity I don't think
empathy such a great thing when it comes
to public policy but in the realm of
private charity it actually is good so
for all people who are all over CNN for
this that's not fair I think that's
unfair to this reporter I think it's
unfair to CNN I think it's unfair to
CNN's coverage okay a little bit of
Bible talk before we part ways so every
Wednesday we do a little bit of Bible
talk here on the bench Shapiro show and
we talk specifically about the the
sections from the prophets this year
because last year we went through the
entirety of the Old Testament first five
books of Moses so now we are doing the
some of the prophets so
this is from this week's haftorah which
is the section of the profits
corresponding to the the section of the
Bible that we read every week this is
from the Book of Isaiah and this is from
Isaiah 54 7:8 says for a small movement
have I forsaken you and with great mercy
will I gather you with a little wrath
did I hide my countenance for a moment
from you and with everlasting kindness
will I have compassion on you says your
Redeemer the Lord and says for this is
to me as the waters of Noah as I swore
that the waters of Noah shall never
again pass over the earth so have I
sworn neither to be wroth with you nor
to rebuke you okay so I thought that
this was a good biblical reading for a
time when so many people have been
evacuated from their homes and what I
mean frankly looks like biblical scale
flooding and this is just incredible
stuff 51 inches in in Texas the US
record I think this speaks to the what
is God doing here you can never talk
about why God allows tragedy to happen
because we just don't know okay there
are certain limits to human
understanding but what God is assuring
us here through Isaiah is the idea that
the status quo for nature the status quo
for a world without God is a world of
chaos in a world of in a world of
disaster and a world of badness I think
there's this bizarre notion in a lot of
philosophers like Rousseau that the
state of nature is grand and glorious
and everybody is getting along and it's
the noble savage and weather is great
and it's on the outside that's really
not how things work nature is has spent
its entire its entire lifespan Nature
has spent its time trying to kill human
beings and nature is is a is it for us
without reckoning so the idea that
without God's protection nature would
overtake us it's true that's what it
means when it doesn't say God is
actively punishing you with storms here
what it says is that God has withdrawn
his face and I'm not speaking to this
particular storm because I can't get
inside God's head I am saying is that
with all the storms physical material
spiritual that we undergo in this life
sometimes that is God just shading his
countenance and that's why it's
important for us to recognize and seek
him out the closer we draw to God
doesn't mean that we're gonna be
protected from disaster I'm not a
preacher of prosperity gospel I don't
believe that belief in God and faith in
God is gonna protect you from bad things
that happen but it is going to allow you
to have more faith that God's
countenance is hidden and will reveal
itself again and that's what this is
talking about now
that God is never gonna hide his
countenance not that there aren't gonna
be times when you don't understand what
God is doing because I don't understand
what God is doing in Texas right now and
neither does anybody else
but understand that God's face will
emerge once again and that God is is is
there even when he's hiding himself even
when we don't know what he's doing he's
still there and that eventually God's
light will shine again and I think it
will try to get on the people of Texas
and I think they're showing tremendous
fortitude and tremendous strength in the
face of a brutal period all of our
thoughts and prayers and yes our charity
goes out to the people in Texas right
now okay we'll be back here tomorrow
with all the latest updates I'm Ben
Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro show
[Music]